is
[Applause]
great moment for those of you listening
not watching cam newton responding to
clay matthews then with the packers
trying to call out the play that the
panthers were running at the goal line
and cam newton says to him you've been
watching film huh watch this and he
throws a touchdown fast not on the wheel
route that clay matthews was calling for
all right we're drafting the most
memorable cam newton moments during his
nine seasons with the carolina panthers
chris i've got the trivia question for
you which will determine the first pick
back in 2011 cam newton became the first
rookie in league history to pass for 4
000 or more yards in a single season
since then two quarterbacks have joined
him as rookies with 4 000 or more
passing yards name them
oh man
i'm gonna oh
wow
um
i'm gonna say carson wentz and i don't
oh no that's not it i don't know go
ahead give it to me
and
andrew luck and jameis winston oh
damn i choked i didn't even come to the
andrew luck thought yet that was uh how
could i forget that geez okay
all right
what's that once that red light goes on
everything changes all right i have a
lot to choose from and and i want to go
positive here
um
he made a throw
during the 2015 season that resulted in
cam newton being the league mvp that was
patrick mahomes before patrick mahomes
it was week 14 against the atlanta
falcons the panthers were up 21-0 they
were going to win the game anyway they
were down near the goal line
and cam newton made a sidearm throw
that somehow
wrapped around the helmet of one falcons
player grazed past the body of another
and was caught diving in the end zone by
tight end ed dixon and i remember at the
time
reacting to that like holy crap
what in the world did he just do and
there it is
full speed doesn't do it justice you got
to see the slow motion there it is
just barely misses the helmet goes over
the arm of the defensive lineman who
dropped into coverage and ed dixon
which impressive to make the catch when
you assume it's going to bounce off of
two other guys but that to me you know
forget about the running forget about
the magnificent spectacular big 50 yard
touchdown that play to me
is uh the thing that was i don't know
foreshadowing what was to come when
patrick holmes got to the nfl because we
see it uh often now but back in 2015 it
was rare and cam newton was the one who
pulled it off yeah no definitely i mean
he's a rare talent and you know just to
that point in the play you're talking
about there i mean a special arm he's
just such a big strong man and a natural
thrower that he can make throws in
awkward positions and you're right
there's a number throughout especially
his early days in the nfl where he's on
his back foot and he's launching 60-yard
bombs right on the money so i'm with you
that was one of the more impressive
throws uh you know of his career
certainly all right i think the first
thing that i would pick here that jumps
out to me more than anything that i'll
remember cam newton for
you know
is his
his post touchdown celebration all right
you know that one is two parts here one
the showing of the superman right i mean
that's become you know
what do i want to say uh it's iconic
iconic exactly thank you for helping me
there for cam newton and you know it's
just him and what he's doing but added
to that
i think one of the coolest things i've
seen here in in recent history the fact
that he was giving ball you know the
footballs the kids in the stands right
that to me it was one of the coolest
things i've seen a player do over the
last few years in the nfl and you would
see kids anytime cam newton was playing
wearing number one jerseys right in the
first row because they were like man cam
newton's gonna score a touchdown and
he's gonna bring if i'm wearing a jersey
of his he's gonna bring a football over
here and i might get it and i just think
that is uh you know just shows the great
person he is and not only just the
player
yeah and that would have been my next
pick that was almost my first pick and i
do have that memory of him he would go
out of his way to make sure he took the
ball over to the stands and give it to a
kid every time not throw it not flip it
not take any chance that some adult is
gonna grab it carry it over hand it to
the kid he did it over and over and over
again and he needs to be commended for
that now we can't have all positive
glowing moments because it's most
memorable and things can be memorable
for good reasons they can be memorable
for bad reasons and one of the first
things i'm going to think of about cam
newton playing in the biggest game of
them all super bowl 50 what happened
with the game on the line what happened
when the ball hit the ground in the
backfield what happened when cam newton
kind of double clutched and froze up and
didn't dive on the football and how he
was criticized about that and it echoed
into his press conference performance
where he got up and left now i
understand why he got up and left they
had a curtain with chris harris jr on
the other side crowing about how they
beat the panthers who were favored to
win but that moment it was so
dissected and studied and watched the
ball's on the ground and what he he
stopped and i don't know you know i
still to this day don't know what he was
thinking um we debuted this show on the
simulcast the next morning and i
remember being up till 2 a.m talking
about writing about thinking about that
moment i don't know if he didn't if he
didn't want to get his legs broken i
don't know what was going on there but
the ball was there and he didn't jump on
it with the season on the line that that
has to be part of his panthers football
obituary
yeah
it does you're right it's on my list too
certainly yeah i think he got caught in
a tough spot listen we're not gonna sit
here and go oh you know he didn't jump
on it because of lack of toughness i
mean it's arguably the toughest
quarterback we've ever seen in football
history i mean he's the only quarterback
we've ever seen who can just be like oh
ray lewis you want to meet me head on in
the hole no problem bam let's do it i
mean that's what but yeah i think he got
stuck there where oh i'm gonna dive on
the ball but he also soared demarcus
ware and he wasn't sure how to dive on
the ball and all those things it wasn't
a good look you're right i think he was
he was trying to he was trying to
anticipate the ball bouncing back out
and scooping it up
there's that one angle there
but but regardless regardless we're
gonna have that moment seared into our
memories of cam newton as a panther no
you're you're right and you know and
again what i want to tell people with
that too is you know i mean cam newton's
going to go down right now as oh he lost
his only super bowl appearance hey
listen the carolina panthers let him
down in that super bowl you know he
threw an interception over the middle of
the field that went right off right
between the two the receiver's two hands
he had a number of big drops from
receiver that day and of course von
miller was the mvp because they couldn't
protect cam newton and carolina tried to
just play the game they wanted to play
all year long if carolina decided that
super bowl hey let's just play to win
this game a lot like what the new
england patriots do if they played to
just say okay
to win it we might have to go 16 to 10
to win it they would have won that super
bowl but they tried to still be this
we're gonna throw the ball down the
field it all backfired all right i'm
sorry i'm blabbering my second pick is
going to be really
the rookie year of cam newton the first
two weeks but specifically week two
against the green bay packers i mean cam
newton came into the league throwing for
400 yards in his first two games as a
rookie nfl quarterback but the week two
match up against the green bay packers
if anybody can remember back 2011
packers were the super bowl champs aaron
rodgers the best quarterback in football
and cam newton yes he threw for 400
yards he threw for three interceptions
and one touchdown but i just remember
watching that game going oh my gosh what
planet is this guy from holy crap how
big is he how fast is he some of the
throws he made in that game with people
on him he was launching 70 yard bombs
and if you remember mike after the game
like aaron rodgers like ran across the
field to like go shake his hand and be
like you're amazing and to me that was
the moment where i went whoa cam newton
is special and has a chance to be
special for a long long time
yeah and and you know it's easy to
forget because
once he becomes established you kind of
forget how it happened like was it
immediate did he have to wait a while it
was immediate it was right out of the
gates it was the panthers got themselves
a franchise quarterback from the moment
he started playing and i think as as
other teams start to remember that that
may make them more inclined to try to
pursue cam newton now that he's a free
agent for the first time in his career
the last one for me and this one is
it's it's personal because and i'm good
it's for me it's going to be memorable
back when the draft happened in 2011 the
year without free agency during the
lockout the only thing that really
happened in the off season was the draft
i was walking down sixth avenue toward
radio city music hall back when they did
the draft there every year
and they had a red carpet set up it was
one of the first years they did that
they were making it gradually a bigger
and bigger event
and
i could see cam newton walking my way as
i was approaching where they were doing
the red carpet
and i see him coming you know and i was
i don't know 50 feet away and
uh
i'm thinking oh they have a platform
they have a raised platform that they
have these quarterbacks you know and the
prospects walking on the red carpet
and then once he got past the end of the
red carpet there was no platform the guy
is a giant i was scared i may have peed
a little i was i was in awe this guy
is and it's one of the reasons why i
think he didn't get as many calls as he
should have gotten during his career he
looks indestructible he looks like
superman he it was amazing how big this
guy's you think you're big sims i mean
you're probably the same height but he's
he's broad and he's huge and just
and you don't you don't pick that up
watching him on tv the way you pick it
up when you see him in person and that
was the first time i ever saw him in
person and i was just flat out amazed
chris no it is amazing when you see him
you're right i mean i i think he's a
little taller than me but his shoulders
are broad i mean he's got you know a
thick chest a thick neck legs and butt
you know i checked that out everything
about it so i mean yeah he's a special
specimen and as i talk about with
quarterbacks a lot of times size is a
skill you know
at times we forget about that and you
know his size has let him
do a lot of things that other
quarterbacks can't do whether that's
thrown in the pocket or making runs and
that's where you know i was just i'm
going like with the general one here
yeah i don't have a specific play
because there's a few of them but mine
was going to be more of like the cam
newton goal line runs i was going to
pick the clay matthews play that we
showed the start you know this little
segment but i don't want to pick that
since we showed it already to me you
know the thing i'm always gonna envision
with cam newton the carolina panthers is
you know i i can't remember what year
houston texans game they're on like the
three yard line he runs up gets flipped
into the air for a touchdown you know i
can remember against the kansas city
chiefs him running over somebody in the
end zone it's just those type of plays
let alone the highlight run plays that
went for 60 and 70 yards you know you
mentioned the size but the size and
athleticism combination to me is really
what makes the guy a special special
player that's why i hope he gets back
healthy because he's fun to watch when
he is 100 healthy he's a game changer
and you know some of those plays whether
it was short yardage goal line or just
scrambling and making big runs you know
some of those runs are what i'll always
remember cam newton buy just a special
special specimen
and there's that tension that i think
existed in the panthers organization
regarding how much do we use them in
that capacity because
even though he looked like superman he
he still was human and he got banged up
still is human still alive he got banged
up he had the shoulder problem he's had
ankle problems he's had the foot problem
and we saw him i remember there was that
the the play at the goal line in week
two and he didn't run and ultimately
they explained uh you know they were
asking ron rivera is the foot injured
can he not push off and they they were
still trying to downplay the foot injury
yeah he couldn't push off it was the
foot injury but they they were willing
to throw caution to the wind with him
physically and he was too and i think
whoever signs him
has to find a better balance chris he's
going to be 31 later this year he needs
to be more careful with his body but
when you're out there on the field and
you see that he's physically dominant
it's tempting to let him just do what he
can do and physically dominate the
problem is eventually he's going to get
injured because we've seen it time and
again
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports